me to get all carl demaio San Diego City
Council member former businessman
current businessman turned mayoral
candidate I'm Chris Reid I'm an
editorial writer for the San Diego
union-tribune and I also I'm a talk show
host on KOCO 600 a.m. San Diego was one
of the first cities back in 2003-2004 to
exhibit the symptoms of the print
pension crisis the deterioration of
services is just obvious and there's
these odd little ways in which people
get reminders over and over again
they'll just drive by a library and
they'll look over there and it's a
Wednesday afternoon and it's closed why
well comprehensive pension reform the
CPR ballot measure is designed to
restore the city of San Diego's
financial health it's an intervention by
the people the voters who want to put an
end to outrageous government pensions
that are both indefensible and
unsustainable government pensions are a
huge problem everywhere so if you've
already got one of the largest cities in
America pursuing this you've got the
little Hoover agency a high-profile
watchdog embracing it this could end up
being strangely enough like the prop 13
of pensions Carl DeMaio the city
councilman who is the primary author of
this could be the Howard Jarvis of the
pension reform moving well this ballot
measure is groundbreaking from a number
of perspectives first it's the only
ballot measure in the nation that deals
with not only new hires but existing
employees the long term hope is that
would save two billion dollars over 25
years going forward and then as you just
have the 401 K employees in the system
there's no problem at all because it's
essentially a pay-as-you-go you know for
the past five and a half months I've
been involved in collecting the
signatures myself and my staff actually
calculated that I've stood personally in
front of stores retail stores over 300
hours since July first alone in the last
six weeks of the campaign we had over
2,500
Sandie Aegon's step forward to help us
collect signatures in every different
way they're trying to pull back from
direct democracy because they fear what
the voters will do if the voters
actually are empowered to to reduce
union power at the local level we are
seeing a union attempts to subvert
direct democracy by attempting to
introduce fraud into the signature
gathering process and that's an ugly
word but there's no other way to get
around it the labor unions check out
these outrageous radio ads saying that
if you signed a ballot measure your
identity would be stolen and sold to
India I just got back from the
supermarket and those pesky signature
gatherers are back please tell me you
didn't sign their petitions I did is
there a problem
you put yourself at risk of identity
theft are you kidding me they even have
my signature I also read the names and
addresses on petitions were found in
countries as far away as India who knows
what they did with it I guess the lesson
is to be careful giving information to
anyone we don't know paid for by
Californians against identity theft and
ballot fraud supported by labor
organizations I laughed and laughed and
laughed when I first heard the air the
add air just like two minutes before I
was supposed to go on one night and it
was obvious to me what was going on I
can't tell you how many people when they
showed up at the stores would say that
the ad was what convinced them to sign
the petition they also hired paid
blockers these are big guys that they
would send out to the stores whenever
they would see a campaign worker
collecting signatures in front of a
store and there would be six seven eight
blockers deep with signs harassing both
the campaign workers as well as store
patrons who were interested in signing
the ballot measure wait so he was out of
cotton guess I walked him
it was shocking that they would go to
these lengths to disrupt which should
ordinarily be a respectful process but
again they they realized that their
arguments probably will not prevail in
the election and the only way they could
stop this reform was by keeping it from
even going to a public vote I just think
that we're kind of a like a junkyard dog
phase here in California democracy where
things are so bad that we're going to
see just a lack of any kind of civility
or a lack of any kind of the basics on
these kind of things because there's a
desperation in the air you know truth is
on our side the financial realities are
very clear you cannot sustain these
sorts of pension payouts in government
and you cannot defend the inequity where
government employees the standard
retirement age is age 55 for the white
collar and blue collar worker for Public
Safety it's age 50 and yet we see so
many sandy Aegon's who can't even fathom
retiring at 67 the age where you start
looking at Social Security the whole
rationale for giving public employees
generous pensions was the notion that
they were paid so poorly they couldn't
possibly save enough during their
careers for retirement that's a bunch of
baloney there's almost no turnover in
the public sector because people are so
satisfied with their jobs
USA Today led the way and it was later
followed up by other groups doing
apples-to-apples comparisons government
lawyers to private lawyers government
middle class managers etc the pay has
been roughly equal for a long time but
the compensation for for a pensions and
health insurance has been triple or
quadruple
and the polling suggests that this is
gonna win the pension reform move
measure will win easily come June so
we'll see but at this point I think
everyone would be astounded if it didn't
win by at least two-to-one margin all
eyes are on San Diego because if we
succeed in San Diego then we are a
national model not only from a financial
standpoint of how to solve this pension
crisis but from a political standpoint
hopefully our victory in the face of
such overwhelming union opposition and
the sort of tactics that they're using
hopefully that victory will embolden
reformers across the country to pick up
this mantle in their own locality and
start advancing pension reform and other
reforms in their City County or state
house